greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by on it listen to new year with a new
set of rules you're trying to get your
life together out of this how it starts
alpha brain shroom tech immune shroom
tech sport all these things can help
your health and mind on a daily basis do
me a favor go to Anna common pressing
church and get 10% off delivered to your
house we can't do anything for you with
the weights and the kettlebells but as
far as supplements are concerned I got
you covered
I like to also welcome manscape calm to
the show you'd think it to manscaped
calm to the show you'd think enjoy what
the [ __ ] is manscape let me ask you a
question are you sick and tired of
looking at your ballsack and your nuts
and your dick and it's all a [ __ ]
feast of hair down that women don't like
that [ __ ] alright you don't have to
suffer anymore you would try to [ __ ]
trim your own ball hairs and stuff like
that how scary is that
you think you might cut your dick off
circumcision meat well you don't need
that stuff they've got precision tools
for your family jewels that's at
manscaped they've redesigned the
electric razor the lawn mower 2.0 is
their handheld razor with skin-safe
technology so i won't sag or Nick your
balls or your [ __ ] dick alright it'll
leave that bad boy nice clean smooth and
pain-free remember what they say if you
trim the hedges the tree looks taller
and that's what I'm talking about so do
me a favor right now the church family
are you [ __ ] savages to get 20% off
your first order when you use code
church at manscape calm right now do me
a favor before we even go any further
just go to manscape calm look at all the
options you got but they got the perfect
package they sent went to lea and one to
me they got raises they got the whole
man's get listen to me you're gonna be a
new man and women are gonna love you
with that [ __ ] dick and that ball
pubic hair and [ __ ] paper toilet free
you're following Santa do me a favor the
full church family gets 20% off their
first order when you use code church at
manscape calm and if you order the
perfect package
don't throw in a free travel bag that
you can use but you gotta use the code
church to get in there
that's manscape comm use promo code
church for 20% off your first order wash
your balls [ __ ] up a shave them and
powder them it's a whole new day out
there
take that [ __ ] meal what's happening
you bad [ __ ] Monday morning
it's a new month you like when having
the Christmas it up your ass it's a
[ __ ] God all right it's February its
valence I got two weeks to get it
together so you better find somebody and
funk and get some chocolates or
something like that huh Vladimir come on
yo is in the house somebody I wanted on
the show for a long time while these
guys have heard them a lot of you guys
haven't I've been here at a bottle for
about two years and a pleasure to
finally have you in the night my friend
what's going on brother I'm hearing that
late man out here for pilot season like
we just talked about trying to figure
out what the next step is the next roll
the next show the next thing and just
trying to keep keep pursuing the dream
how are you now 37 bro and you started
comedy 111 years ago ten years ago in
New York Oh 807 around there after
college yeah I graduated three from
college what major I was a psychology
major okay perfect I was a chemistry
major for the first three years couldn't
couldn't hack it wasn't my thing then I
suppose the worst I can't see the
Dominican Republic turn them powder with
the paste and originally from and by the
way the pharmacist you know how it is in
like Latino communities they treat him
like he's the doctor he's the [ __ ]
doc they torment your [ __ ] life on
your farm and this guy just puts pills
and bottles and act like he's the doctor
oh you're kidding what do you recommend
for for a broken elbow I'll do it you
put a little bit right there you're good
Spanish people buy into that yes man if
you watch Spanish TV
come on late at night they sell
everything if you fat you take a pill
and that's why you see people Spanish
people fatter than [ __ ] we don't have it
we don't ask for evidence they have
[ __ ] paperwork that you drink that
you put in your food and it takes all
the calories out they sell all the bad
price
yes bro and then they then your mother
says it's all eluding Co yeah it's the
one thing like you said that about the
last ten medications mom how is this the
one thing that's gonna turn the tide
when I was a kid I was raised I had a
mole ship of God
oh my god did I there's so much vitamin
A if you're not careful a motive of cod
from the ages of four to about ten and
then she gave up well what was the
reason just to fortify you just uh she
was scared and I gotta be honest here
that ship makes you as strong as a bull
now they have a strawberry flavor ever I
have I walked past CVS I always see it
but I know it tastes when you drank it
was straight in the street it started
straight out of a spoon and then I cried
for a long time then I made my mom mix
it with orange juice and they would
curdle just just Harvick just already
what it does Diaz a kid but it yoked me
up is I was always a sickly kid ah as he
coughs as he coughs
yeah no no but this I had cultural
problems my tonsils are swell up I was
allergic to maple syrup I was allergic
to a lot of foods back then and I would
swell up or it was just a [ __ ] you
know how you being like an emergency
room every week for a month one time
damn I'm like four to five and once I
started going to kindergarten in New
York you start breathing all those
[ __ ] journal of nasty kids your
defenses go up you do they go away you
got no choice again they go way up you
know New York in the 70 and that was
dirty New York dirty New York needles on
the street he cold I started there right
that's week old I started you know a lot
of chefs that's what we're eating paint
chips what's the alert was in that lab
was everywhere bright paint chip eating
continental garden the [ __ ] kid
seconds the tap water tasted like silver
Mercury yeah you can't get all that tap
water in Jersey yeah when I went to
McKinley that that dungeon he said
torture people done they put pipes and
you drank from it it's like you and you
drink and go ah like it was delicious
it's so weird how water is such a scam
like that's the biggest scam we buy what
you know what the water in this view
makes every [ __ ] billions of dollars
billions of dollars and the billions and
every week there's a new water company
and its water from a backyard at the end
of the day its water from the backyard a
couple years ago been in town to the
show called [ __ ] yeah I'm sure I
remember that yeah show time one of the
first places they went there was a water
bar in Hollywood a water bar there was a
bar in Hollywood ten years ago that was
called the water bar people telling me
about that you going on there interest
of all these waters from around the
world like stinky Charlie like a key Ric
[ __ ] Theo's friend that he used to
have oh yeah from all over the world the
guy even though wait wait what are you
talking about don't everyone we'd ever
get like a slab of ice from like Iceland
and then melt it and put like mint in it
and you would be drinking water from
Iceland
so these [ __ ] Penn & Teller
went down and took a hose in the back
and just filled it up and gave people
hose water and I couldn't tell different
people were like we really like this
water this shit's just [ __ ] it's
just mold of dude the water industry is
the biggest [ __ ] industry that we
believe it they give me the same one you
have a water filter home when you drink
straight out of town next well I have
water I get thinking water by the gallon
right so I don't know if it's good and
now who the [ __ ] knows what's in there
you just drink it and pray for the best
you know you're getting scammed right
you know you're getting scammed they're
not getting any water any different from
anywhere else
have you let me travel though when you
travel to different places do you find
differences in the water when you shower
cuz I've been in some places were like a
shower skin is less dry you know hair is
better other places like still you feel
like it's like my mother's show I'm
still fat that's all that matters if you
find me a warm that makes me skin like
Jesus water that's the fountain I need
if I'm still fat I don't know I've never
really thought about it
I love showers so do i bro I could sit
in the shower for an hour the best jokes
I ever write is one I'm sitting the
shower for two hours he said coach I was
a hotshot hot hot by switching up the
cold back the hot steam and sometimes of
its steam and
sit on the side of the wall and make
believe I'm a homeless guy that lives
under the train and he lives next and he
gets steamed I do a lot of [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] in the shower you have a nice
shower when you hooked out the chances
I'm coming back to you have you the
steam rooms are not like steam room and
so on yeah I love that stuff bro
the Hollywood why has the best double
punch combination
what's double punch double points I got
the steam next to the sauna Oh for real
to the pool right outside of it I know a
bit to the Hollywood why oh yeah and
Schrader
what's the strainer right on the earth
right before you hit fine what's the
Hollywood white charge in these days
it's up there but you know lunchtime you
go upstairs and play hoops Denzel
Washington at the Hollywood wire
yeah they play hoops at lunchtime I'm
talking about Mike ball is like I'm
living in front because I lived across
the street from it and for years I would
avoid it when I was 400 pounds I wanted
The Longest Yard
I made believe it was like a woman show
what I'm getting beat up and put over
that another by the gym over there and
then I saw the the bass player from the
Red Hot Chili Peppers one day about 11
dribble the ball down the block and he's
what's what he doing here he was that
played ball to [ __ ] my everyday lunch I
mean even gonna I started hearing the
rumors and then me and my wife joined I
became in love with it that's where I
first lost the first hundred pounds is
that that why you felt comfortable that
you thought I was the [ __ ] best the
first time I want that one is as a
swimmer that was the easiest day I could
do so I'm going to a fat man pool they
got like a little bit full it's 3 feet
90 degrees and just float like it was a
picture you like oh my god I would go in
there like at 4:45 in the morning I was
so embarrassed
my opens up before in those days the Y
opened up at 4:45 and I'd walk right in
at 4:45 what's how would you get up 420
Jesus a cup of coffee smoke a joint
pregame like pre-workout pretty a
prerunner okay
over there and I would sit in the steam
first the wooden one that you throw
water on the rock yeah yeah the song yes
in their first warm-up Kabaddi match in
there and now we're going to the steam
room and put eucalyptus on that
[ __ ] and they'll tell you not to
throw water on it I throw gallons in
there you couldn't even look it was like
[ __ ] there could be a [ __ ] black
dude sitting next to you didn't thought
it was so much fun that [ __ ] room no
when they walk in you hey what's up
[ __ ] what yeah and then I were going
back into the steam and then I would do
a lap I'd do a half hour in the pool
kicking moving my arms just when I was
418 out I was still I wasn't athletic I
had just stopped exercising so I just
went back in the pool went back to
basics started pulling myself and [ __ ]
but I did that for a few months and then
I just started punching the bag I would
hit the bag there in the afternoons I
would go there like a quarter of the
night he would close the tent so go to
quarter line I would hit the bag and
ride a stationary bicycle but something
happened when they I jump in the pool I
won in the afternoon and I thought that
the kid the fat man pool was gonna be
open and it was filled with Russian
women bunch of kids Bissonnette so I
signed up for the Olympic pool I put my
name when they looked the pool not even
[ __ ] thinking I put my goggles on all
that I swim at before I went to prison I
swam I was part of the master strong
program in Boulder and I swear three
times a week [ __ ] all out with the
coach time is I learned backstroke every
style everything don't you pay you're
doing all the stroke you get in there
and they'd have a blackboard or what you
had to do
level one how to do eight eight 80s with
the 30-second rest and two-minute
intervals level two how to do this in
Colorado has higher elevation to how oh
yes and when you went and if it snowed
you still had a go it was outside I was
out to a point it would shovel the
[ __ ] path from the locker room to the
two entrances in the diving wood and you
had to walk through the snow and jump in
it was a heated pool okay oh that was
gonna say yeah it was a heated pool so I
learned how to swim
I went back into this so I get there
that's I said me gonna tell a little bit
pool and without thinking I jumped
because it was completely different it's
like 58 degrees which right away
exhausted you right out of your [ __ ]
lungs bro little pool I'm like four laps
in and there's people next to me like
what's going like boats just flying and
I'm going for my life I'm swimming I'm
doing everything I can I'm kicking I got
the form down before I pop up and I spun
backwards like I was pointing like two
o'clock in that direction and I don't
you to triangle thought I was already
starting to dry land I just held on to
the Rope and people like stop holding on
for the rope and then when they would
take off I would swim from Rome II don't
like Tarzan under the pool of light for
the edge and that's what the sopranos
who's really hot so I kept walking into
this why Aries the one day I'm one of
the afternoon as soon as I walk in these
three little lifeguards come up to me
that I get it that dude the surprise I'm
like dog get the [ __ ] away from here not
to do from The Sopranos leave me alone
so now I'm drowning I'm holding onto the
warm they see this and like mister
mister you okay I go get me out of there
I can't breathe they could see it like I
was in panic panic attack the color from
my face is gone I was trying to lose
like righteousness and [ __ ] and they hit
the buzzer they hit the panic button for
will you come in Wow embarrassment
embarrassment and then they told me swim
to the middle and we'll drop a hoist in
to pull you out like Orca swim like bro
useless I mean are they just sitting on
and how can we make this more embarrass
you and they go let's go back and I know
that's what I'm saying isn't this like
is it the writers room they danced there
we're gonna drop a net in and then you
swim into the net and the net pulls you
out and then the thing comes around and
I'm like guys I can't swim back out
there like my legs are done I'm done
like and this is this is crazy and
finally they're going let's pull them
out so all the three of these little
three little Mexican Mexican kids got
one on
the chicks got the other arm up for 18
I'm panicking I'm trying to keep it
together and they're pulling they're
pulling they're pulling ain't nothing
going on
Melissa God if you get my model I got
here
I will go to church every [ __ ] it's
all about goals we'll get the one leg
out God said the one leg oh I threw that
190 pound piece of meat over and I hope
they're for humans they had me by
they're pacing Lee you gotta pace
yourself
and I spun myself over and I roll like
two or three times and I got up like
miraculously it everybody had stopped
the fool asleep bro barakatuh
miraculously because I was out of breath
I was all huff to buff that now I had to
pick up 418 pounds I ran with a bikini
nine inches of fat hanging over the
bikini from all direction you're wearing
speedo no I would never wear speed up no
matter what I wore I was hanging six
inches over and I'm in the middle of
this [ __ ] huge Olympic pool and the
people of frozen every time is free to
take and thank God I put my towel like
most people petition a locker don't
trust nobody
I kept my towel with a warm-up jacket
and my keys to the house and the wall of
jacket like ten feet away and while
they're talking to me like are you okay
do you want oxygen I'm like yeah I look
and I see the ambulance they call the
ambulance ah me bro
how can we make this more embarrassed
and I see them coming in like with the
thing and I put my jag and I put the
whole nut in disguise it's like a side
door that went around I came out through
the [ __ ] side with a locker when you
go into the Y you're gonna be going the
girls side of the boys side
I came through there the little kids
kept running after mister mister the
ambience is he and they want to help you
know my [ __ ] red band I just got him
pulled on he had I took it out of bull
he called an ambulance on himself and
they charged him 1,800 bucks to go so I
said [ __ ] yeah that's all I kept
thinking about was 1800 hang your nobody
1800
and Doug as I walked out of there the
kids kept saying to me are you gonna be
okay you gonna be able to work on the
soprano I'm like I'm not before I said
that I go yeah I'm gonna be working on
the Sopranos that I just walked out and
left and never came back from the
embarrassment and then about four months
later I went in there and nobody said a
word to me till about five years later I
see a kid from the Y at the vet I go to
I had to pick up food for my cat and I
see the young kid through a different
kid from the Y there I had known him for
maybe a month as I get in my car I felt
bad like are you gonna know why he was
yeah I do I live right across the street
you want a ride he goes yeah go get in
the car when you get in the car we start
driving like oh I won't even work out
the way you know just more chatter you
know a couple years ago I almost found
that the why and without missing a beat
and he didn't look at me cuz I know
that's the first story they told me when
I got the job there I probably saw on
the security footage they probably have
the tape so no lumps in it [ __ ]
oh you're part of like the training
program like I just when you get him out
the car well you said listen this stays
between us no I didn't say that I was
just like in a way I was shocked but I
wasn't surprised I still kept going I
still bed the embarrassment what what
are you gonna do dude I was I wasn't
that big I was a chubby kid in the in
like in like grade school in high school
and I hate it when you were playing
basketball and they would say shirts and
skins as you know shirts and scares is
one team shirtless one team shirts I was
at a tournament in the heights with my
older brother and they said we couldn't
afford I couldn't afford t-shirts for
both teams so they had one scene with
shirts and they're like the Redskins I
happen to be on the skins team bro I
disappeared
no one knew where I was at before
cellphones and they were short like a
man because I was like I'm not wearing
skins to play ball bro
these titties are not leaving the shirt
because of the shame you feel the shame
I would have traded my
I'm gonna go to the alleged I should
have been I should negotiated a trade
the abiding have an agent at the time to
to navigate those waters but yes shame
bro like showing your bodies a big deal
well you the kid that would wear a
t-shirt like to the pool given that guy
wasn't that wasn't a that kid it was at
Walden when you got older when I got
here was Ryan got fat all that I was
always in good shape and I would you
know I didn't really I wasn't body
conscious at all you got what you get
Brian your family you get [ __ ] up
shows you get [ __ ] up shell visit you
can sit at home on Saturday so you can
go out of the pool make-believe Mike you
[ __ ] Superman and that's exactly what
I did I'm you may believe like I was
just a regular person you know like
whatever body disposition you have
you're not gonna stay at home I met a
girl here years ago we didn't Dana
anything we were friends there was
something that we were gonna do at the
beach and I said to it with the Comedy
Store she was a waitress right now let's
say you gonna go to the event and she
goes annulled to go to outdoor events I
go why not she goes does that means you
gotta wear shorts I gotta show my legs
hmm and this girl was really pretty but
she felt her legs were too short
and now if I saying guys don't give a
[ __ ] about your legs they just give a
[ __ ] about what's between the [ __ ]
legs right you know I don't worry about
your legs she was like I'm really
embarrassed about my calves my legs so
Liza
I'm looking into surgery really like
have implants have implants right yeah
this is 20 years ago she's long gone you
know I you know she's just a nice girl
that worked store that nice cars you bro
nice cars like my dad my dad when I was
growing up he hated like shape-ups like
you know you get a haircut the barber
gives you shape up he was like I saw
that eating that's what hoodlums do
Hold'em so I go to school with a haircut
but no shape up so my line was just a
road map teachers would make fun of me
kids make fun of me I think in my first
shape up till I was a senior in high
school and if you know you New York you
know you know New York jory haircuts
matter the haircut you got the fade you
know that the line up like that matters
that girls like and the boy was born in
the heights I was born in the heights
and then the height of the first few
hundred a first tree that's the Millican
of the minute
you know what it is there used to be
Jewish right neighborhood changed my
aunt my aunt husband was a super on
181st and for Washington okay so they
used to be a movie theater do the corner
yes black movie theater and then down
the block there was another one that
showed two four not five dollar movie I
think the one right before Broadway
right right right the Coliseum when you
step in the flows mad sticky because
nobody cleaned it right for twenty years
bro Lee this was a fit it was filthy in
there bro and then fifty yards that was
a Carvel yo the Carvel was now [ __ ] do
you think you're dealing with Joe is the
first place I tried ice cream a cake
that was dog that's my [ __ ] what I I
knew about that neighbor as a child and
I went up there to cop we don't 179 by
the button oh right by the block we get
off the bus and I would walk two blocks
I would shoplift starving my sturdy
itami I got a job working on 57th and
eleventh at those car dealerships way
out that's where on the way on the
Westside way on the west side so I would
go over the George Washington Bridge
there one morning as that woke up I
didn't have money for the [ __ ] bus
Wow I walked it I would have enough for
a bagel or the bus it would either be a
bagel on a coke pan or a bus so I would
take the [ __ ] bagel and then go to
Safeway I'd have a briefcase like a
Salesman with a suit and I'd steal yeast
infection medication and aspirins and
then I'd walk it across the bridge and
all those bodegas on the other side they
would buy all that [ __ ] East infection
and boxes from me and do denim and then
I would take my money my drugs breakfast
and I had money for the rest of the day
where'd you get the idea to sell that to
the bodegas where'd you get the junkies
told me junkies would do that that's
like it's like a TED talk junkies would
do that tell me all the time whenever
you need money go to Fort Lee or
somewhere there's shoplift
yeast infection like auntie said offend
me know like I said I'm an offender like
high level aspirin and there was
something else they like I can't know
what it was that they sold a lot
so there was such a big East infection
population in that area every I would
throw I would go to the Safeway and they
would have like the ten of them on the
shelf but then right over it they would
have a box of that I would just take the
whole box and put in the briefcase and
walk over and never gave me like 35 a
box at $70 Wow so if you get off on 170
hash cash if you get off on 178 they
used to be OTB I'll track betting but I
still there I think it's best times I
had in my life creepiest people you'll
ever see the best fist fights ever where
the OTB and you think that UFC is good
if you go to the ho chi beyond what's
already bro honor 78 so I had a system I
would get off Port Authority across the
street and that's one selling diet right
there I know exactly what it is I would
walk down the corner and there would be
cube instead
this is 1984 83 84 so crack hasn't hit
yet crack was hit but it wasn't on that
block that block was strictly reefer it
was Cuban refugees from Marielle and you
would go down there by weed there was a
mold a guy going there get a [ __ ]
Coco Rico and a pack of rolling papers
Easy Rider and I go in the alley I'd
[ __ ] roll the joint I haven't walked
within those days with a cassette and I
play the Walker and walk back to
Broadway smoking a joint and then when I
hit 187 I go down to 176
there was a Cuban restaurant of dead
mice had me six my Broadway right there
that was a Cuban restaurant right around
the corner there was a park so sometimes
I would go to the Cuban restaurant go to
the bathroom roll another joy is that by
that big feeder
yes so church be old sure yeah old
church we're in sleepers that might say
what's the name of that dealer you don't
you know I'm talking about right I
remember the theater and then down the
corn is the hospital yeah exactly live
is the hand on Broadway I know that I
knew that area like that you know how
many times I want a nap Dean it because
it was windy and I would just like for
the joint in the corner and smoke it to
try to get the window you know many
times I went to that theater that was my
hangout neighborhood because I worked on
52nd and seventh
so I didn't have to be in till 5:00 you
know me dog I'm literally rise
I gotta pretend ready to rock before I
am to go hit the pool yeah I would
[ __ ] go into the city go do all that
all that [ __ ] was done by 11:30 so by
the time 11:30 came I had an option
I could go to carve out and hit the two
movie Pete in a double feature that's
why I saw a peaceful heart and Scarface
you talked to Scott missing the theaters
weight but they replayed it with fifa
hearts thief of hearts is a movie
Stephen Bauer did two or three years
later it was horrendous it was
horrendous they were trying to parlay
the Scarface anything with a thief of
hearts it was thief of hearts Scarface
then I saw that's the first time I have
a sat through I saw office in the
gentlemen and I saw a [ __ ] American
Gigolo crazy and that's the I see an
American Gigolo
and I hated Richard Gere but I went too
often the gentleman is I had to kill two
hours of work I was cold out there but
it was one of my favorite movies and
then so now we'll always have a choice
between 178 or Hajin 81st on the corner
108th first is a black movie theater I
was a different different different
crowd from vibe right this was the other
place it's a sticky floor where it was
filthy and people drag because I think I
left a short poem there oh my god who
knows what they showed it was terrible
you I think I got bugs there I wouldn't
be surprised I got crabs in there it was
disgusting the tickets wasn't living
like tickets yeah there was a gala for
two movie it was a rout oh man who's a
dollar yeah 1985 but if you walked 50
yards up they have like a modern lows
[ __ ] right in the first movie I wanted
to see in there was the Shogun of Harlem
you talking about are you talking about
the last dragon the last dragon and
black people were going crazy night have
you seen a movie Lee I that's the first
oh these are cultural moments that's in
New York that's the first time I saw I
had heard about black movie theaters I
had heard about black people or movie
theaters that's tough and there's a
movie theater scene in that movie yes
there's a movie theater system
yes so with Mary gourd add Berry Gordy's
The Last Dragon
that's tremendous movie the congas
shogun holland which he just died in
music series he just died two years ago
that we pulled up we even pull up it was
on like that it was like I'm Twitter
it's a sad day martial artist you know
such a classic the Harlem died [ __ ]
vanity vanity was Anthony was thy mother
villain got the Puranas yeah they got
with the Puranas in the guy I met fellas
who got a feeling that this is Bodyguard
the guy I totally totally untraceable
he used to pre plays The Bodyguard to a
little guy in there the villain yeah
that was that guy than a thousand movie
roles god bless him he was a character
actor I see little paradise and let the
stories Frenchy and Goodfellas he played
French for real yeah he's Frenchie and
Goodfellas same guy Rogan those are
really well hilarious but I'm gonna tell
you what movie taught me the most about
life about african-american people deep
down inside bro african-american people
love white people they really do and
that's why they get so hurt because
every black person every
african-american person you meet have
you talked to him a little bring get to
know him they dig something white and
they're ashamed to say like I had an
african-american friend that wouldn't
tell nobody he was a [ __ ] beetle in
the 70s of you like you gonna tell them
all [ __ ] you like the Beatles they
smack you yeah three black cousins I see
your point
I see no there was something about
certain values that were associated with
whiteness because I remember having
similar experiences in grade school in
high school do you believe the king of
that you read something about why he
gnashed [ __ ] you know I mean right I'm
sorry you hide it cuz you're right it
was associated with like white society
and it was a shame thing about it like
but you're right it's it's there was a
guy while I meant what I did The Longest
Yard my dear friend her husband was
african-american and we had been dear
friends
I mean dear friends even content you can
copy grew up in gangs ish right the
whole [ __ ] thing
and do you know what she told me once
she goes Joey he's on his way to
Hollywood to take a picture cuz he wants
to be a an extra anything the longest
shot
I thought what are you talking about he
goes he's a big Adam Sandler fan your
husband the gang member with the gun
yeah he thinks Adam Sandler's like Jesus
Christ
so african-americans really do love they
have wine heroes they really do they
have to be like me I'm CUBAN I had why
they rough they have to be and we love
the Godfather
we love the Godfather so guess what
movie I saw then they black people
almost kill each other and I've watched
a thousand movies I want to guys this
one year was this 85 are they were
really white movie uh no no no he said
85 I saw something I thought black
people were gonna kill everybody in that
movie alright listen I want to guess
this give me a hint was it was ever come
to New York was it it wasn't it's uh
it's uh it's uh the harvey movie I mean
other live viewers commenting trying to
guess this know okay cuz this is good
trivia an army movie eighty-five we'll
listen I ain't no Houdini Rambo for real
I would never guess that bro
when Rambo shot that Japanese do with
the arrow that exploded black people's
heads or more blue the [ __ ] up really
what the scene that made them so crazy
wasn't he hit himself in the mud and the
Russian was looking for him and also his
eyes opened up and he came out and
stabbed the dude black people when they
were high five and going that's my
[ __ ]
Rambo's my [ __ ] that's a
[ __ ] but when he pulled that
arrow back and blew that Vietnamese guy
off because in that time he had arrows
that had explosives and the guy shooting
at him and then he runs and then he
shoots at him and he realizes out of
bullets and also ran ball pulls the
thing back and you could hear every
black person going oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] no he ain't no no
no and when the Vietnamese guy blew up
they [ __ ] all were up on their feet
yelling high-fiving what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
my Luther King they were [ __ ] a rowdy
chopping each other than that I never
said I was like this dog I was looking
back on oh my god
well he shot that Vietnamese do with the
arrow and that do blew up
african-americans went [ __ ] nuts they
walked out of there happier than [ __ ]
well he does that speech in the end bro
I had a joke once I'm about because
Netflix has his new show called black
mirror black what black mirror bag and I
was at the Gotham comedy club but
everybody's like oh my god it's so
interactive you can interact like yeah
we've been doing that for years like you
go to any Peter in New York like in
those days we're interacting with the
movie saying I'm of a 42nd Street that
was 42nd Street brought porn and then
and people get into arguments like if
you went to a movie named you play hooky
and went to Louie the daytime you know
in those days at the mental house they
may give you like a day pass like a bus
ticket no recess and give you like a
little movie ticket and you would go to
the movie ticket by yourself so a lot of
movie theaters in the daytime the
matinee or [ __ ] up people in New York
those days like that bought little
yellow bus to pull up and you see my
guys walk out that was schizophrenic and
[ __ ] and they are watching like a Jaa's
brats and moving [ __ ] I still remember I
would never fly today
that is hilarious that's to kidnap
people like super San Francisco in 85
and spending a dollar for three cronies
with movies like Dirty Harry the other
one and the other one you're going there
at 11:00 in the morning you don't walk
out till 5:00 and then it starts again
at 6:00 and you know what got till
midnight I mean you got to be a [ __ ]
animal to go to those but people it was
packed and it's an incredible in San
Francisco and it was that one scene in
one movie we shot like four black dudes
first then three more but then some
black guy got out in the back of this
how to be any sick
he got up in the back legs I could be
shoot one more [ __ ] I'm leaving epic
I'm like what the [ __ ]
and he said but what I want to ask you
boy shut up man I want to ask you about
is what was it like and I hope you did
what was it like wanna see Bruce Lee
movies in the theater did you get that
opportunity to see it as I did yes I did
you can't describe it you can't people
forget how in inner city Bruce was a
bomb dude like we would lose our minds
watching those movies listen the Vietnam
War made this country lose a lot of hope
you know like it the country was in a
weird time I had just gotten here from
Cuba black people of African Americans
will fight for their should have done
their 25th Street Harlem right while
they had a born on the 27th Street you
could feel the tension there was a
different pride to the African American
in New York I still remember walk with
my best friend the black kid Jasper
Williams walking like on Broadway don't
line to our mothers that we're gonna go
play checkers and I want him to buy the
new James Brown hot pants I panicked I
still remember me and we gonna walking
like 128 first and Broadway
like nobody at the age of 5 walk five
blocks crazy New York in New York my
daughter would never [ __ ] walk five
blocks I'd kill her bro you weren't even
that I go to the grocery store myself no
but you know it was a different time
people with people people were you know
you had a homie with you nobody was
gonna snatch you up but when Bruce Lee
came Bruce Lee first appeared on The
Green Hornet correct and then he
disappeared that's probably really knew
what was going on nobody knew his name
just people like what happened to the
Green Hornet then Fist of Fury came he
went to China that's right the first one
and that it was popular but it didn't
win them over
it didn't really win him oh but I'm
talking to you from in New York mm-hmm
going to see Fist of Fury
I saw Fist of Fury at the Union City
hilarious those days on 48th Street of
course in the barber we're talking about
barbers and he was my barber his name
was ina lethal he would cut your hair
and they would put spray in your hair
like like even if he didn't wanna that's
she given tea he'd give it to you math
shiny for no reason it that he put
purple lights aren't you and go meet
elope
that's what be time I say you get them
tips baby that you would be looking a
little like oh sure I'm a legend baby
I'm a king get some [ __ ] these streets
you got nothing but he was right across
the street from there I remember going
to see that movie and like gone back
that night like my mom had a bar on 29th
Street so 48 she was at a movie theater
was it had to be had to be seven a crane
Leslie came out and then he released
then I was in Catholic school which one
what are you going to Sacred Heart
School for Boys and Carlee New Jersey ok
the third to the fifth grade and the
fourth grade I still remember taking
showers being in our pajamas and sitting
around watching happy days like 14 other
kids in the dormitory and all of a
sudden they showed the trailer like we
were all talking them between
commercials like yeah we're gonna play
tag tomorrow and all of a sudden on the
trail of the Chinese connection and the
room went silent sucked the air out of
the room the trailer just took the air
out of the room you loo this is gonna be
big I still in my step dad and mom my
mom and my stepdad picking me up on
Friday Thursday night am I gonna get us
anything I'm gonna be 10 do you want to
go into Manhattan to see a godmother and
I'm like we're gonna see Bruce Lee
tonight like I'm finding a way to go to
see Bruce day and they're like we had so
many plans no and I still and my father
taking me the seat but you gotta know
before Bruce Lee came movie five thing
is the death five thing as a death
kicked off the Asian scene with the red
hand and the iron palm technique then
Bruce Lee came which made it harder but
five fingers a death kicked down the
door five fingers at their kick down the
door
and then once we hit that's it New York
had become a colorful cultural event yo
that was it was living time yes man
that's what I want they were all doing
the whole talking about Hakan and karate
and go to everything became kungfu
because that's a Bruce Lee bit
everybody wanted to study Wing Chun
there was no Wing Chun in New York maybe
one guy in the East Village
he had 9,000 students if you watch
Martin there's a scene even the show
Martin if we could that's the scene from
Frank connection Bruce goes why did you
kill my teacher why why
tremendous dude it was and there with
that that like you have she's um she's
great now that's all great but like the
eighties martial arts when when Steven
Seagal came out in Van Damme and all
that stuff
nothing nothing compared because there
was more going on Ryan you're talking
about New York's let me tell you what
was going on in New York that destroyed
New York
so while Bruce Lee is kicking the [ __ ]
out of people and we're all in movie
theaters you [ __ ] don't believe
me [ __ ] you better go up and drop
your stats right now because I just I
hate major league baseball but it stuck
up my thing cuz I don't know how to
change it unserious
yeah when I bought the car I got major
league baseball this morning I was
wondering why he hit the stage yeah I
don't know nothing about three studio
54s Island he wasn't at 3:00 this
morning they were talking about it
[ __ ] the Cincinnati Reds going with
independent and then the next season
being they barely made 500 and he
started talking about there was
something going on in this country at
this point the [ __ ] the message just
one will you we believe you gotta
believe was the slogan [ __ ] New York
City was on fire it was 1969 and [ __ ]
New York was dirty there was garbage
everywhere the rats garbage truck I
remember as a kid we did everything in
the day time but one thing we did three
times a week I swear to my daughter as
we kill a rat we that's the rats came on
the daytime they didn't give a [ __ ] jack
we'd be out like in like horror and go
what the [ __ ] is that it's not a rat and
we chase it and hit it with rocks and
then sticks so and it will and then run
over with a [ __ ] bicycle and
to all that that we light it on fire we
put glue on it we like the [ __ ]
joy like people hear this and they
probably like oh my god that's not funny
the reason I laugh is because to me
that's nostalgia I've seen my dad
barefoot with a broom kill rats yeah
putting a black garbage bag and toss it
out buff away like nothing yeah but he
let it on fire that that's another stat
when you 267 that's a ton of us will be
kicking this rat the rat would be [ __ ]
a footlong ah the rats were big boots go
changed and you would see them on the
corner in between the tires that's how
we would see him so we would always have
our eyes out for rats very seldom did
you see what they always we'd see him at
six once it got doctors always that fat
one that can't wait he comes out a
little early for the [ __ ] for the
moonlight special we should do a
voiceover with Joe he is like the nature
narrator yeah steam coming out six
o'clock the fat one yeah the fat [ __ ] we
would get in your mother would be a
little bad awesome she will go out the
window and we'd have the rat those days
we wouldn't touch it we push him with a
broomstick broomstick there you go and
then we kill him he would still be half
alive and then we start getting rock go
get rocks start throwing rocks at the
[ __ ] then bottles and then we
[ __ ] get a bicycle run over his head
it was crazy and then we pour [ __ ]
butane lighter and then we dried them on
fire we just sit there [ __ ] you [ __ ]
don't come on this block no more and
[ __ ] we were just yell it was [ __ ]
great then we used to take the bottom
off in chairs there was silver caps you
took the bottom oh but that one - what
I'm telling you people because it all
went together you know Brooklyn is the
fourth largest city in the nation but
the other rack is correct the other
thing that Brooklyn holds a lot of
people are noise it has every immigrant
every consumer world has a
representative there whether it's a half
a block whatever it's a block mmm it's a
melting pot for a lot of things and I
love it I love that you go to Brooklyn
get Dominican food from one side right I
love making food and you make the food
you do this stuff whether I like it or
not it's it's a reality
but the early 70s in New York was
focused basically on Dominicans Puerto
Ricans not that many Dominicans yet
Dominicans Puerto Ricans and Italians
Tommy Boy Italians Jewish right Jewish a
lot of Jewish and the Vietnam War was
going on so a lot of people were losing
their faith but there was two faiths
that there was a couple people that
weren't losing their faith
you know why people because a baseball
black people because of Bruce Lee
because even if he wasn't black he was
to represent the narrow minority and you
had another guy that people forget I
can't say his name because I could said
you had a guy that was a complete
gentleman his name was Roberto Clemente
oh my god man you absolutely okay this
guy there's a statue of him in the Bronx
when you go to the state park if if if
if you have to talk about not just a
baseball player but a gentleman all the
way around this guy if you want to be a
man today's world black Latino - yes
whatever we can do you want to [ __ ]
be a man in today's world do me a favor
don't listen to me that was the [ __ ]
Joe Rogan those occur all these [ __ ]
go read about Roberto Clemente reading
his stats read watch the videos of what
he would do watch this [ __ ] watch him
every time he did an interview he had a
shirt and Thailand and his English was
perfect he would find it disrespectful
to not talk English but his English was
perfect he was the perfect Latino so he
represented this was what New York was
everybody loves baseball every borough
Clemente was baseball if you like
baseball
whether you hated blacks whites whatever
[ __ ] Roberto Clemente was doing
something Pittsburgh that was never seen
before he hit that [ __ ] two or three
thousand hits in Denmark he got his 3000
you know it's not how many people you
shoot it's who you shoot like he's gonna
[ __ ] he could've got the 3,000 hits in
Pittsburgh we got in New York but he
goes let me do this really kids in New
York these [ __ ] it down when he
hit that 3000 hit against the Mets
Puerto Ricans are stabbing each other
yes man jumping up and down
I mind you this is it against the New
York team team that loves them cuz know
everybody loved Roberto Clemente listen
everybody white black the guy was a
Dodger and they didn't touch him didn't
talk to him because he was half dark
that's a true story
Pittsburgh got him for like a dollar
Kingsburg got him right we got him on
eBay great what about this guy over here
in the corner he's a black guy guitar
wasn't a movie made why isn't everybody
moving because this country were doesn't
know her brother Clemente it's a waste
of the investment they would not
understand what a man is of that caliber
they would not understand you just said
it yourself
you're dead recovery he loses all his
mind you got Charles Bronson yeah these
are my dad's heroes Charles Bronson my
hero yeah Tony's my heroes it's so funny
that I talk about it but I think about
this kid a lot daily one of my best
friends growing up was Dominican and he
was from Houston Street my his name is
Louie Ananas I like you he was very
dark-skinned they had long afro but he
moved he moved into the wrong
neighborhood he moved into my
neighborhood mmm so right away they
called him Louie the [ __ ] tell people
why he's Dominican right what's the same
[ __ ] no one ain't no one ain't he's
[ __ ] Spanish
down these mean streets beauty Thomas
but he was cool as [ __ ] and I still
things a psychiatrist today be for real
yeah he's a psychiatrist in New York
City could jump that Dominican could
jump jack he had legs he could jump as a
[ __ ] kid he got more slam dunk in the
8th grade by an inch or two it's a great
story think I became a psychiatrist
that's an amazing stories after he got
tortured all those Jews that's what I'm
saying like it makes it's a nice
redemptive story but Clemente bro
Clemente was my father with Clemente
died you didn't see Spanish people for a
week it was so sad when he died he died
New Year's Day you opened up the year
with the death or Oberto Clemente 19 it
was devastating for a lot of people man
so now now you got Bruce Lee holding the
tow Bruce Lee was holding the Bell
that was it Bruce Lee was represented
bro he had a new movie coming out his
[ __ ] and the movie was gonna kick ass
and every Saturday we'd go down to
Chinatown and we buy [ __ ] Ying Ying
juice like [ __ ] to drink mm-hmm [ __ ]
that we put on a bag and get your hands
on it and make believe your hands got
strong and I would walk around with the
Bruce Lee outfit on yeah yeah yeah yeah
and when dragon came out we lost our
minds and then there was no internet
there was no news from China there was
no breaking news oh we went to Chinatown
and we found that Bruce Lee back Wow and
I remember all five or six of us just
broke down into tears right there and
they had pictures from the funeral you
know Steve McQueen and James Coburn and
the thing over his eye and that changed
America that changed America you know
last night I was telling about why we're
watching the u.s. versus John Lennon
when John Lennon moved to after he did
all the anti-war [ __ ] he moved to New
York and he made New York this home but
I was a kid with gentleman who died I
never saw anything like that in my life
when John Lennon died that was you yeah
New York I mean you you they told you
don't bring the car in that was 40 years
ago we're almost right 1980 he died so
yeah yeah steady nine [ __ ] years they
told you don't bring the car in cuz it's
gonna be that bad they way you look at
if you go all the time look at anything
from YouTube John Lennon his death look
what was going on around the country bro
people felt it
people thought that and the Beatles
couldn't get back together so people
like me were happy and I could talk [ __ ]
you know saying [ __ ] you with you
Beatles I gotta let Zeppelin this [ __ ]
unless I'm saying that you know this and
so when you guys what made you get into
comedy um I can share this with you Joey
you know you you um your upbringing is
so chaotic you know granted you had you
know I've heard some of your stories you
know stuff it's a lot more you know
sporadic and just
chaos - you know but like who knows why
you do comedy right like the easy answer
is like uh trying to make my mother
laugh or something like that I don't
know but I still don't know why to
comment I don't know why I just I'm
drawn to it I love it you know I think
I'm funny some days I'm not as funny as
I think I am I just think that comedy is
the essence you know it's who you are
and that's if you want it the universe
says you gotta go do this
you gotta go do this bro I mean your
story's crazy the prison the drug and
yet still you got the telling jokes
that's a that's a genetic as a genetic
thing bro that's like I said like
nothing could have stopped you from
doing that and it's proven that you
everything your life story like
everything you thrown at you you still
up there telling I didn't give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you can't once you start giving a
[ __ ] they win but the problem people
fake not giving a [ __ ] yeah no no no you
can't you have to go through it's
another [ __ ] there we go one day I
ain't paying no bills I ain't paying the
government I ain't paying taxes I ain't
doing [ __ ] I'm doing this my way [ __ ]
everybody
oh you make me laugh cuz it's only such
a thing to say what do you want me to
say you want me to apologize for my
actions I've done I did my time what was
that moment what you were like I just I
I've had it I'm not going back I'm sure
I'm a different person now as soon as I
walked out of prison I knew I wasn't
going back but you can't change somebody
over that I talk about rehabilitation is
a big process to jump you are who you
are they [ __ ] baptize you because
you're born a thief
mmm it's a control your thievery you
know I'm sayin how much you gonna steal
is up to you after I got a prison yeah I
still hustled for about six or seven
years I did illegal things but not to
the point where but if I got caught I
was a do major time you know a little
drug deals here and they bought just to
stay alive
[ __ ] just to stay alive once I got out
here and I got to the comedy store I
slurred there was a little beam of hope
because for anybody who wants to get
their life change they just need to see
a light of hope little a little faith a
little belief
this is possible this is possible and
now is wood with discipline comes in now
is where you got to keep your hands in
your pockets because that's when don't
let your character ruin your destiny I
didn't know that saying at first but I
learned it and I saw myself do it at the
Comedy Store like I saw a thousand
things like a Rob at the comedy saying I
saw purses I saw people making mistakes
right
and you ain't so you went from reflex to
choice the choice now this is what I
have to do I'm here
I wandered I'm when I'm on the Triple A
League I'm at the farm team of the
Yankees and there's only one outfielder
ahead of me he's 38 I got this I'm right
here I'm gonna [ __ ] up them and that's
when you have to remember it's it's easy
to [ __ ] up when you're doing well that's
when you [ __ ] up when you're doing well
it's not what you're doing bad you're
doing bad you don't give a [ __ ] about a
fire I forgot to pay the light bill you
do dumb [ __ ] when you're doing well
that's when you don't think about
something ma'am you don't see the
problems your own [ __ ] TMZ or your
something so lose track of reality you
almost not connected in reality that's
why it's success sometimes it's [ __ ]
up because you have to be ready for it
the pants for it know how to handle it
and know I had to go through it with no
stress I've heard a funny quote from
this guy named Michael Beckwith he said
uh fate is what's given to you destiny
is what you do with it that's it and I
found that soul impact I think man that
makes a lot of sense
sometimes God opens up the door for you
but we don't have the balls to go
through it because we know it's gonna
change our life but was scared of change
mmm would naturally scare the change
I want it take you to do comedy and
start getting known around the New York
area eight years eight nine years eight
eight nine years then you went to
Montreal and I did just for laughs in
2015 that's when everything kind of
kicked off in terms of like on a
significant level so to speak got the
pilot deal shadow
n-b-c got a bigger agency and then the
pilot doesn't get picked up and you love
kind of holding your hands you're like
yo it was such a massive disappointment
because you thinking this is a great
opportunity to tell a specific story
from New York and someone from New York
you get it like the stuff you're talking
about the rats and all that stuff like
people don't understand man like for
people like us like those stories mean
so much it's a it's a moment in New York
and I get it was terrible but it's a
moment and to have an opportunity to
share those stories on TV that's what I
wanted and then when they pull it away
from you're like oh god man like I had
an opportunity to show in New York dad
to show New York Latino that is a super
like that character everybody in New
York knows him and how hard he worked
and how hard he had to get then raising
a family in the crack era you know my
father my father living it was a little
crack the whole building a the whole
street and you got to raise three kids
with that input and to not have that
story be told it was like it's crushing
bro you feel like what's next like you
go on staged
well my pilot well my pilot didn't get
picked up I had a gig in indiana's and
crackers I was headlining there and it's
one of those weekend's where they go
listen you're headlining but there's the
Indy 500 so no one's coming to your show
so I'm doing a show for like ten people
in Indiana and I'm like you go from this
high of shooting a pilot and are you
doing a show for ten people and you
can't you kind of go what's real what's
real man like the hell's going on it was
such a mind warp for a couple months man
you know therapy and friends and family
all other stuff but you know it's tough
it's a brutal very young you don't
understand
the town throws a lot of stuff at you
quickly why are you shooting a pilot you
get a lot of smoke blowing up your ass
by people that made you a little crazy
and it's a big letdown huge like bomb
and I can't I I moved here to shoot a
pilot and I went from having a page the
dialogue I said then I was done with the
one-line demise I'm just standing there
but the pilot was still gonna get picked
up
hopefully heaven it was CBS his answer
to him YPD blue
there's gonna be a drama a little bit of
comedy and they put two million in so
they paid the director two million
dollars to shoot it cuz it was a really
good director I forget what his name was
and it didn't get picked up was I
disappointed yes yeah that one killed me
because I expected to get out of my home
I knew it wasn't gonna save my life but
I knew would keep me above ground with
four episodes of like 8208 on that
person yeah you make some money you got
something that was 32 grand I was
looking at 34 [ __ ] grand and you know
when they said no I was like [ __ ] that's
that could have been like an apartment
furniture a down payment on the car I
could pay some child support off buys
you time it buys you advise you times
are you trying to do with my time at
that so how do you feel today like how
do you feel um I die I feel I feel I
feel uh I feel great man just one of
those things were lucky kind of yeah
blessed to have the opportunity you have
a sense of gratitude about everything a
lot of people don't get to shoot a pilot
you know these are champagne problems
there's people with bigger problems and
I made a lot of friends a lot of but I
did notice when I'm pausing he picked up
was like relationships matter you know
like friendships matter and those things
matter because and because pilots come
and go but friendships memories who you
know who you don't know you know we
still people like stop working so much
about pitching it and worry about
connecting the people because sometimes
the people that get the offers are the
ones that that they feel most connected
with we can work with this guy we can
succeed with this guy who can win with
this guy and trying to get the pitch for
the opportunity it's like you know you
read Kevin Hart's book right Kevin Hart
book how they were ready yet and he was
like in $400,000 in debt kid on the way
bleak bleak you know and through a
series of different events and
opportunities he came out the other side
but it was a long journey between when
he got just four laughs and that half a
million dollar deal and when he became
Kevin Hart like you said isn't somebody
no one's talking about the
disappointments like I was talking to
Adam Ferrara one time and he had a pilot
pole he shot
and so each shared with me his
I won't tell her because it's his story
but you start to realize that other
comics other good comics the good ones
this is part of the path the good comics
have these major disappointments Richard
Pryor had it when he walked out that
Shana Vegas Chapelle had him when he had
that Variety magazine theme what they
call Tim erases the good comics they
realize when they hit that wall like I
have nothing else to do this is it I got
to tell these jokes there's no wall
right right that stage and that
microphone is always there and I saw the
thousand times I saw thousand good
comics that came to this town got a TV
deal [ __ ] basically told us every
other comic at all with all three clubs
to go [ __ ] himself
Wow I mean they drank the [ __ ] ruling
right at Montreal they kind of walked
away from Tom it was a hip RAAS s they
shot the pilot they bought a new car the
wife and him Waterloo House and awesome
and put his [ __ ] okay picked up and now
the comic is on limbo now you start to
see him six months later he doesn't say
much to anybody he's doing spots he
tries to get on stage but he quit comedy
he flung his fingers that one got him to
the damn high you gave a thing that
don't got you to the dance
I don't you were [ __ ] me for shooting
for two pilots and you make sure to get
that for like Tom beast or Saturday or
something
now Adam the truth I shoot to show I
said I don't just work out once a week
and you keep those chops up I can name
ten comics today and that would have
been stars if they didn't ring the
[ __ ] juice and they took off of these
reasons and that reason is their right
and now they want to catch up in the
game because they show is coming right
at Bretton bothers gun but when they had
the opportunity while the show was done
they never thought about these things
because you're trying to retain these
people you try them to come to your show
and to come back again the start of
relationship where you on social media
it's a different game today it's not
what it used to be when you first got to
the comedy store right and you said that
was a beacon of light for you beacon of
life how did you how did you sustain
yourself psychologically because is it
you have a go
like I want to get famous or was it like
I'm just gonna keep doing this and see
where it takes me
I just want to keep doing this to
seaward day right there was no thought
of Fame there was no thought of movies
there was no thought of films there was
no thought of TV because of my past I
held on all my sins get in the way and I
always told myself I wasn't good enough
for that [ __ ] so if I'm lucky just to
get spots I was just playing the hand I
was basically playing the hand I didn't
know that and then I would say six more
months you might be the commercial six
more months I've been commercial six
more months I've become there was always
something every six months that kept me
crazy
the whole time I'm doing six spots at
The Comedy Store to spot some Willie's
room and two spots with Felipe in a room
on a Sunday night so I kept getting
better economy unknowingly
just doing it unknowingly you're just
improving and Montreal don't like you
the three agencies don't like you the
top management teams don't like you
you're not perfect for this you're not
right for this you're not right for that
okay I [ __ ] let me take an acting
class I took an acting class 25 halls a
session I did that for a few weeks to
get him like comics yeah he didn't like
comedians because he had a bad
experience with dice mango is his name
and then I joined another acting place
and then Josh wolf got a deal and he
gave me the 500 bucks to join up to the
other acting place and I went to the
acting plant so I started booking movies
because I knew stand-up the doors will
be closed on me so I figured if stand-up
wasn't a closed at door I'm going
through the back door to acting but now
the rules aren't acting changed it used
to be when I got it if you booked two TV
shows that's it
next thing you know people buying
tickets to go see then another and I
kept booking and booking and booked and
nothing got the longest yard
I'll wait till the movie comes out bro
Shh this movie comes out bro you might
as well go buy a Porsche right now
entire movie came out nobody called and
yeah I got how the agent called me to
book me out in the road but I was
getting 60 people walking in and when I
get off stays it be seven because I walk
right and they thought that we want to
see that understand the character that
they're talking about [ __ ] something
[ __ ] or cocaine rocks and my choking
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that but it's the
adjustments you make this career is all
about audibles you have a plan you're
gonna write your plan out I wrote my
plan out for the year already
yes I'm here so what I want all right
happened but there's gonna be audibles
every 90 days is gonna be inaudible so
now you got to switch up that plan now
what you wanted to do in November now
you might be due in January with you you
follow me yes course corrections so this
is always Honorables that's a comedy has
a lot of things that a lot of people
can't do this is just not getting up on
stage and cracking jokes and writing
then after you get to where you're going
then you got to figure out the strategy
to stay the way you want him and to keep
improving and then you got to come up
with another strategy and it's just
strategies this is a game [ __ ] with
strategies if you really think about it
and right now you're at 37 seven your
first deal was given to you when you
were 34 34 35 34 35
you know what man you might not see
another deal now - you're 42
who knows you'll see it yeah you'll see
another one another - they'll get hot on
you from a different angle the best
thing was you never gave up when I saw
you on the stage of flap was that night
I was so [ __ ] happy because I know
this kid never gave up that's a good
point right there a lot of people after
that pilots don't get picked up they
take this money get very bitter - a lot
of guys get together I said boy saw tons
of people come in the late 90s and early
2000s and you would feel insecure like
you'd see these peoples live change a
half million dollar deal you clear three
hundred that's the part that's not
that's a nice that's a nice chunk of
change so they took a change
you know to get you started that way for
the hundred the bank let you do set you
to going to kill yourself right up front
to desperations gone yeah that
desperations got not everybody gets that
so everybody was getting those except me
can we talk a little bit about because I
I know Joey you said you've never you
heard they didn't want you now and I
won't go or can't go but like you talked
about how big Montreal like is just I'm
like I'm wondering what it feels like to
kill a month like you were talking about
going from high to low like to kill at
Montreal and get a deal there like that
must be it wanted never happens anymore
so I was I was the rare occasion and I
remember telling my therapist I was like
you know I don't know I don't know if
they're gonna get me up there they can
understand me that kind of thing and I
killed I crushed up there you know and
like it what it does for a comic in in
an external way that legitimizes you you
know you have to legitimize yourself
again of the date but externally it's
like oh this kid is legit or he's
legitimate stand up you know and the
industry takes you seriously I'll take a
meeting with you now that's what just
relax does you know and you meet
everybody Chappelle's walking around you
know I did a show with Sebastian
Maniscalco and in 2015 when he sold out
like seven shows at the small Church
this big show and it's my first I was in
the back with him and his wife and at
the time I was like Sebastian was like
the guy you know you stand up [ __ ]
gun he said to stand ups like he wasn't
like as populist but the stand ups knew
like oh Sebastian you know and I've got
to open up for him and was this thing of
like you know you know Sebastian story
being a waiter at the four seasons and
then and then doing spots at The Comedy
Store in between like you know going
into debt at one point and having his
dad repaying back I found this stuff out
later but then you meet him and you're
like oh this is possible like this guy
left Chicago to go to LA now he's
headlining at the Just for Laughs comedy
festival selling stuff out
he comes from an immigrant family like
oh this is possible you know that was
dabbled with just for last was like oh
this is possible it's this feeling of
like possibility like oh this can happen
you meet people from all over the world
coming here to watch these shows and
it's the biggest feather the biggest
Comedy Festival you know like
the people you meet that is their
friends for life and you always go back
to that like yo he and I did new faces
in 2015 you know you have those stories
to go back on a point when was the first
time you showcase from run through I did
it three times that I got it I got it
the third year third yeah how many years
did you do comedy before you shied I was
doing comedy five years when I first
showcased and I was doing it eight when
I got it eight years and when I got it
eight years and when I got it and again
eight years of New York is a different
eight years now no offense to anybody
but eight years in New York is doing
four or five sets a night while having a
day job you know I'm saying you see me
build a danger I'd serve rob was a I was
a grants administrator at a nonprofit
law firm I was a like an office manager
for a small nonprofit that's my last gig
not had a great boss his name of Jeremy
and he was super nice but you're doing
these sets so like three in the morning
and then getting up to go to work doing
that for years you know and doing like
it shows it driving out to Philadelphia
for like 50 bucks you know driving them
to upstate for 100 bucks or whatever it
is so I never work with Rodger Paul but
I know of Rodger Paul but this guy's
like Tom Tom and jr. at Omni pop they
give you a little feature work at the
stress factory and those days when you
got a feature work at the feature spot
like the feature spot was so dope cuz
you had six shows lined up Thursday
Friday Saturday Sunday
you had like he was so happy man you
were getting paid you like I got feature
work you know and so I was doing that
for years and then I then I kind of got
some heat but you know what it is 8:00
in New York is a very different time
cause of the subway so you can do a show
in Brooklyn take the subway back to
Manhattan then you can do show downtown
Lower East Side and shoot up back to
Times Square do another show so that
whole time between spots you're writing
that joke didn't work at this problemi
change it up for this show you'd find it
up then you go to the comic strip
they'd have a late-night thing there and
then you know you jump on a spot
somebody canceled you know la la I find
to be very different you know you you
you grew here and develop but I finally
York to be more conducive to young
comics in terms of developing and
getting that muscle yeah this is not a
good place it's hard and it's hard it's
hard to hear it's very hard to hear
you have distractions the open mic gasps
monster yes man this open mic errs and
it's the whole population of in a way
that are in LA start hearing things that
they shouldn't write you're in the
conversations that you shouldn't even be
worried if I step outside Ryan you're in
conversations that are you correct you
have eight years from worried about
correct so go solar correct you should
not be talking about this this is the
problem you have here they start wobble
bad
I heard that too Starbucks on vine if
you do common hair there's an agent that
shows up there that's five years just to
grow you gotta figure out how to get
into the dirtiest scum yeah man and make
those people laugh and then worry about
and that's why I don't like Tom here
trust me a lot of people have grown and
listened to it
I've had some terrible shows I'm sure
you had worse because I always hear
stories about comedians like I was gonna
comedy like to thousands around there
and I would do the quote-unquote hood
rooms or urban rooms I was gonna show us
what you know crazies like the World
Series is on and you're trying to tell
jokes you know like when you say the
trenches like those things exist those
things and they were worse in your day
they were worse than your dealer I think
they gotten better now like now could
doc guys doing shows in the back of
comic book stores and oh your coffee
shops and you know like it's a very warm
for the artist which is great which I I
love but you're right there were days
when you're doing shows in the worst
conditions with this dream of like maybe
I could do something with this one you
know you want five people clapping Brian
you work hard you look at you striving
those eight years did you ever feel
frustrated what I what I was always
struggling with Joey and I'm curious to
hear what your take on this is you write
this material right you write this
material in your house you write it but
then you realize the circumstances
change when you get on stage so it's
like you can't work on the material you
got to work on what is needed in that
moment and that's what comedy is it's
like deconstructing yourself updated
this like what
you roll put the to the side that's not
it's not gonna work here we want you we
want to see you and it's time for that
you have a piece of material right can
you bring it up on stage when you're
first starting out when you're first
learning on I mean oh when you first
yeah the problem is like different store
yeah different game different game
uneven I wrote all the writing books yes
man yes you got to put working yeah
books let's move on that muscle
I would only write down what I thought
of I would sit there with a notebook for
an hour and write one thing and that's
good enough for me
you know I'm saying I wouldn't keep
adding and adding to me I could do two
on here and I could find two other
add-ons while I'm working it out on
stage just from their reactions right
you know and then you start depending on
their reaction and then one day you get
a different reaction so let me say
something else see what you just talked
about a lot of people don't have no see
you're in the fighting stance okay
you're in a fighting stance you throw a
jab right you throw a jab at him he
throws a jab at you where's it gonna hit
he's aiming over here so I'm gonna take
the jab this way block it and I'm gonna
unleash that right hand I'm not gonna
get back and you throw it I'm gonna
block and win it I'm gonna let it out
right and then I'm gonna give you an
inside kick to the leg and then I'm
gonna throw another punch of your head
that's what we're doing that's a set up
but today right but when you go on stage
you're gonna realize here we go you're
gonna realize that that [ __ ] leg cake
then that first punch isn't as smooth as
you thought right you gotta take a step
back and then throw yes and that punch
guess what if that punch don't connect
if he goes down you could scoop his neck
and name in the face that's what you
realize when you go up on stage you're
not gonna get that sitting at your house
no for a guy like me you're gonna get
that on stage when you get to a place
like like it's like like chess masters
talked about this like when they get
good they realize like
there's just this possibilities are
endless like you said once you like the
possibilities up here are endless I pay
you something I don't want to tell you
the truth go ahead one brand myself I'll
go ahead it's like when I do the
original right I've legitimately been
doing the original for 20 years
interesting I couldn't bother there even
if I wore litter I know all the cheap
nuts of that room I would never sell
them he does that it would take you a
lot to get but even if but even if you
told on even let's say let's say [ __ ]
understand that's what I'm saying you
still go do it yes man you're gonna pay
me for something that you're gonna have
to find you can give me obviously blad
he's all good you can kill cheat codes
and I wouldn't be able to do it I won't
happen though I won't even know our last
let and just leveled them and I hope
giggling the whole time because I'm like
this wouldn't work anywhere else oh
really
yeah oh I got cheat notes for the
original there they won't work another
Club the original has to cheat notes
that you have to do every time and
you'll get them and I sit there and I
see comics don't do it and I'm like it's
the [ __ ] original however though
because you know the cheat codes here's
what happens though Joey you're able to
now yeah yeah yeah damn metal level now
now you am I able to genuinely reflect
on your craft cuz you got that out the
way I got the chief I know how to kill
this room but guess what else I got if I
give you the cheat notes
you're gonna go up there and stick the
last cheat notes so if those cheat notes
don't work you're not gonna know what to
do I know what to do even if you guys
don't [ __ ] there we go
so I expect yes to dunk but even though
you don't duck and you stay down now I
gotta improvise again so I know the
cheat note for the cheat know now cuz
I'm better than you or better this time
just time in the game where the years
there's time in the game it's 21 years
you're gonna come tell me something
about that room twenty years I walked in
there with every time I go in there I
had her anxious you would see the why
I'm not gonna bomb it was a killing a
snake
someone soldiers killed ahead of me yeah
it would although though forget it so so
once was watching tonight what about
killed me what am I gonna do no no no no
I died a thousand dances there so now I
know how to live you know I was telling
George Perez and one of the managers
last night the story go doc 20 years I
just thought again good in the man look
for 10 I hate [ __ ]
if the bag Mitzi sure not to put me in
there that's why she put me in there I
was so stupid I shoulda asked her
interesting can you book me the baby
make me uncomfortable I would tell her
don't put me in that dog I don't like it
in there I'm putting you in there live
in 45 you're going down my right have a
good time those days following dumb you
rather shoot you so what did you what
did you learn there in those in those
dog [ __ ] years like what did you learn
about yourself
I learned cuz obviously you're funny
that I had a then no matter what
happened and this applies to life this
is why I love comedy this is why I can
never ever have a day job because I want
my day to be different every day number
one number two I want to be striving for
a different goal every day number three
what happens I can't this is the house I
came from I came from a Spanish house
that in my house there was a rule a
little boy that I second no point in
telling that guy so get out rank I came
to it look up well until I am back I
said when I'm monologuing and SEMA
booyah what that means is you can never
stay it I grew up in a house that was
[ __ ] put into my mind drilled as a
young man by not a male or a female
which it makes it even worse that you do
not come into this house stay hid now
most people listen to I go enjoy I don't
know what you mean it means that just
because you lost today doesn't mean you
don't lose tomorrow when you're an open
mic er the first five six years listen
to me
you know those Vietnam vets have helped
over in Hanoi they even feel better than
you do could you go back like looking at
now could you go back and do what you
did to get into comedy do you think you
have the wherewithal to go through that
again I didn't have a choice right right
right
going from me there was no way I was
going to work for an electrician he is
before I can open up my own company I
didn't have the time I knew the cocaine
would kill me
I knew the cocaine the Gulf to my
closets me pull my gun on somebody by
mistake wasn't I and me getting
desperate we're gonna kill me I needed
something to save me and this is what it
was so you're gonna go out some nights
and bomb three times yeah man in life
you're gonna go on an interview for day
and bomb and bomb you're gonna go for
three interviews on Monday two on
Tuesday on dates I'm gonna go on dates
and bomb you're gonna bomb and every
people bomb in life people forget that
how many times you on a date but check
his heart you start taking off her ass
if she pulls a knob Z I'm sorry she
sucks your pipe then you eat her [ __ ]
ba ba ba ba ba ba and she's nice
afterward she talks to you she's nice
and you said let's do this again and
she's not or she's just a fun check but
once you take the home when you get back
in the car you go damn I forgot to pull
ahead I forgot to put my finger in her
ass and turn it into a popsicle either
[ __ ] and pick her up and then so what
do you do you go back to the next night
you take it to the movie you're sitting
there throughout the whole movie anxious
tonight I'm really gonna give a dick
tonight you don't even know what the
performance anxiety right yeah you just
[ __ ] sitting in and my point is that
you go home at night you feel bad bro my
day when I first started comedy I had so
many bad things going through my was the
process losing my daughter sorry how
this broke I owe 200,000
I had nothing going for me I was a
junkie I didn't want to hand up that
[ __ ] whole guy with nothing so the
stakes were that high so when I would
come home those nights I would get a
gram of coke I would get a notebook like
this I would open up a newspaper that
was called something that it was a
comedy newspaper that was at every
comedy club and I would look through the
names of the clubs but I wanted to
perform at the Seattle Denver Comedy
Works punch slides improv let's go and I
would write them down in a notebook and
I would I stood with my tears it is the
page as we go on Sunday I'm gonna play
in these clubs so what did I bomb
tonight I'm gonna show them tomorrow Wow
I became like a serial killer
you know a little gear man cave and
revenge and it was all about comedy my
[ __ ] focus was calmly tomorrow you're
gonna go out be better than when you
went snow dreaming yeah today I did 13
minutes next Monday I'm gonna do 17
minutes or you know you know just
talking yourself out and then reading it
and seeing the strength of that children
into your eyes rock bottom rock bottom
like rock bottom so in my house you
don't stay hit if you're part of the
church you never stay hit so what you
had a bad day so what so what everybody
has and guess what how about if you have
to bad day somebody if you bomb six
times in two days right
wait no you go home you get a notebook I
don't want you to bail on your material
I don't really want you to bet on your
material if this is what's coming to
your heart I just want you how to
present it to me you're not presenting
it to me right I'm sick and tired of
[ __ ] a how the audience isn't Austin
any different from there they are yes
the human beings no no I'm just I'm just
saying yeah absolutely the general young
comic I know I know I know exactly the
same stiff audience is never still it's
you and those eight stiffs that you hang
out with that a [ __ ] stiff audience
is great how do you know because after
all night E is a guy with a pulse came
and got a stand
got a pulse came a guy with a policy all
he did was breathe into a glass and jump
up and down with a flashlight and he got
a standing ovation and you 9mu Tosh's
could but instead of those nine guys
going home and saying riding on their
journal the audience was kind of stiff
going no I sucked mmm what can I do to
make it better what jokes did I try this
this let's add a tag here
let's move this around let's try this
new joke in the middle instead of
opening up to this new joke which i
think is garbage genome saying that's
what and that's the process every day
every day I can't imagine your core
savages because you go from set to set
doing this and set the set I do it at
the store Thursday I gotta go to the
store I already have something I want to
try it but I forgot to try last night
about [ __ ] how Irish people are by
the FOB future panel you know I don't
know it was juicy there was juicy juicy
I'll get you out of here you have any
dates right now no I'm in ellika
policies okay I'm Claire pfann to come
back on before I'd love to come back on
you leave for New York yeah just a month
I never have people turn around because
I want to hear more about you
I like the Spanish great that you have I
like that you're educated
you came from good stock you're
Dominican Dominican should be proud of
[ __ ] do you remember when they [ __ ]
threw the toilet off the roof and killed
the rookie top 100 million oh that's the
Dominicans for shabby
[Laughter]
no no no I'm sorry didn't take they ran
under so it's Broadway what's behind
broad wodsworth before if i'm coming
from jersey of the law of the George
Washington Bridge were Washington right
Broadway
what's that Street Hein Hearst they
[ __ ] took their spackle pocket but
when the Dominicans were lookouts on the
roofs and if they would see the cops
they would take 5-gallon spackle buckets
and throw it and they killed the [ __ ]
top for the spackle bucket it's crazy
bro that's 1993 bro that's and
Dominicans got a lock I'm the [ __ ]
Upper West Side I used to get all my
coke all that I used to get off at Port
Authority
walk to the corner and then walk down
and those buildings that you see as
you're about to hit New York right there
they're right there easy access you
walked in you could double Park and get
right back on the bridge but you never
took the car and back this and they
impound it so you came over in the
George Washington and you went back on
the Lincoln you stopped and got a hot
dog 11th Avenue and kill time so they
were you off the climb Vladimir I love
you any dates coming up no man I'm in LA
for pilot season I'm working I'm working
in a laying o comedy magic club Laugh
Factory I'm around
laughing glidecam laughing Vlad yeah it
was a real pressure you're a phenomenal
young man with a great [ __ ] the
future thank you brother they're ready
and you know we're boys man you know I
mean I love you the deadline to drop it
into labor thanks for having me man they
break alright I want to thank my me of
Vladimir c'mon yo for a very interesting
podcast Lee great kid I love the debt
don't forget I'll be at the San Jose
improv ticket to just left a Valentine's
Day and for Friday late that Center
Friday early one of those shows Saturday
is gone and late I don't know what the
[ __ ] it is get whatever you got left you
[ __ ] savages you know I love you I
can't wait to go to San Jose's get that
[ __ ] original jokes then on February
22nd Viva Las Vegas I'm a [ __ ]
Treasure Island where's your
[ __ ] Island with my girl cake
quickly and then we go over to the Fox
Toussaint either the Fox Theater in
Tucson with my girl Kate Quigley Tempe
Phoenix I'm not coming there this year
so if you want to see uncle you got to
come to [ __ ] Tucson lead some tacos
Amir right so I either see it the Fox
Theatre in Tucson Treasure Island in Las
Vegas or the San Jose improv
listen I want to give a shout out to my
sponsors real quick first of all I want
to welcome manscape listen there's
nothing more scarier than shaving in
that sack or your dick sac around your
dick nothing more scary
I used my wife cuz I don't trust myself
after three years I could have said this
is my stomach but now I can see it but I
still use my wife and the whole time I
look straight ahead and I pray and I
think everything that I've done that's
[ __ ] bad in my life but guess what
you don't got to suffer anymore with
manscaped
you could get it done without
the pain the [ __ ] anxiety the [ __ ]
slamming cajuste they got precision
tools for your [ __ ] family
jewels you understand me manscaped has
redesigned the electric razor
the lawnmower 2.0 is a handheld razor
with skin-safe technology so it won't
Nick or snag your balls or all that
[ __ ] baseball bat you got for a dick
this bad boy will leave your helmet and
nutsack clean smooth and pain-free plus
it's rechargeable and easy to hold so
you can get into all the nooks and
[ __ ] crannies and pick up your leg
like a cat and get in between your
[ __ ] in your nutsack there's a little
area called the sting festival that's
where those little sticky hairs grow you
want to get that down and they got a
classic safety razor called the plow
that will give you a smooth shave
without the bumps you understand me you
ever go down on a chick and she's got
those razor moocs you don't need those
things you will not get them with
manscape and you know what they say if
you trim the hedges the tree looks
[ __ ] taller so that means if you got
a two-inch dick you're running with six
now they don't know nothing about
mathematics guys I got anyway at
manscape calm you got everything you
need to make your balls and dick shine
and look beautiful you I'm saying it's
looking at the flag it's just out there
a [ __ ] pole of debt this is the first
time you consider manscaping they got
the deal for you it's called the perfect
package it comes with the lawn mower and
the plow Plus that's the crop preserver
especially formulated anti chafing
deodorant for your balls so they don't
stink like [ __ ] ten dead [ __ ]
Iranians and they got the revival a
spritz that tones and refreshes your
junk to keep your dick and your ballsack
nice and cool and fresh it's like
putting bengay on your balls but not
really and I'm saying so what I'm doing
for you guys is this listen to the left
Church family all you [ __ ] savages
and you need to listen if you don't get
what I'm gonna be pissed off at you
[ __ ] cuz I want my church so
just look I want your dicks and your
[ __ ] and your [ __ ] ball sacks to
look tip-top Magoo so the church family
can get 20% off your first order when
you use promo code church at manscape
calm
that's manscape calm that's manscape
calm em ANS CA PE be calm and if you
order the perfect package that includes
the lawnmower the plow the cop is the
crop preserver and the Reviver
listen I'm 56 I need to revive I smell a
little that [ __ ] holy water on my
dick it just [ __ ] moves around like a
dead fish out on the [ __ ] plank
anyway go to manscape dot-com use promo
code Church and get 20 [ __ ]
percent off your first order wash your
balls shave your balls you want you
wanna pick up chicks this is the way to
do it a nice clean helmet and nice and
if you want to put like a [ __ ]
diamond above your dick I'm sure you can
do it they have a booklet somewhere go
to manscape calm right now go to
manscape calm right now I also want to
thank on it number one when it comes to
supplements in my world you understand
me out for brain you get a hundred
percent off and I don't even want the
product back who the [ __ ] does that you
got any friends that do that [ __ ] no
that's why I trust on it whether it's a
shroom tech sport the shroom tech
community got those daily vitamin
packages a tremendous that the Mexican
chocolate protein you have no [ __ ]
idea what you're missing you understand
me
I trust or breed with all my [ __ ]
heart that guy goes all over the world
looking for the best of the best so if
you're looking to be the best you got to
eat what the best is he gonna calm right
now and press in church and get 10% off
your order delivered to your
[ __ ] house alright listen
it's a beautiful gonna be alive thank
you for listening to the Church of
what's happened now
see you Wednesday or Thursday don't
sweat nothin that's it I'll see your
[ __ ] soon thank you for
listening to have a great day I love you